[Musique]
un grand merci à tous un grand merci à
tous vous savez une différence
fondamentale entre notre tête de liste
et la tête de liste en marche la tête de
liste en marche il la cache notre tête
de liste on est fiers de l'entendre
voilà et je suis fier surtout de ce qui
s'est passé dans notre famille politique
je suis fier de ce déclic qui a eu lieu
je suis fier de voir que semaine après
semaine
il ya un élan qui s'est reconstruit une
envie qui revenu je suis fier de ce qu'a
fait françois xavier avec le trio début
puis ensuite avec tous ceux qui sont
autour de lui quand les sondages nous
donner à 8% et que maintenant on est
selon les sondages entre 13 à 15%
conte et la liste qui a le plus
progressé depuis le début de la campagne
et je suis très confiant dans l'issue
parce que je suis convaincu qu'il ya une
dynamique qui nous porte
il ya quelque chose de profond qui est
en train de se jouer dans le pays et que
sous-estiment tous ceux qui voudraient
faire quoi au fond ceux qui cherchent à
nous dire c'est que c'est la réédition
du second tour de la présidentielle mais
ça n'est pas le troisième tour de la
présidentielle les français ont le choix
sur la table de vote
il n'y aura pas que deux bulletins
emmanuel macron est obsédé par une seule
chose son seul but c'est battre marine
le pen le seul objectif de marine le pen
c'est de battre emmanuel macron mais les
français ne sont pas là pour éliminer
cette fois ci cette fois-ci les français
peuvent s'exprimer en fonction de leurs
convictions et je dis à tous ceux qui
sont ceux qui sont attachés aux valeurs
de la droite et du centre
exprimez-vous par rapport à vos
convictions exprimez-vous par rapport à
ce que vous voulez pour la france
exprimez-vous par rapport à ce que vous
voulez pour l'europe
cette fois-ci vous n'avez pas besoin
d'éliminer cette fois-ci vous pouvez
choisir
choisissez la liste d'union de la droite
et du centre
et en matière européenne ici comment ne
pas mieux le comprendre comment ne pas
mieux comprendre ici à quel point ce que
propose tout à la fois marine le pen
emmanuel macron est une double impasse
le bric site ce qui est en train
d'emmener le royaume uni dans le chaos
ce que vous mieux que personne vous
savez parce que vous regardez ce qui est
en train de se passer ici de près mais
quand les britanniques ont voté ils ont
voté en écoutant exactement les mêmes
discours que ceux de marine le pen quand
les britanniques ont voté ils ont voté
pour des gens qui portait exactement lé
même idée que marine le pen et cela
aboutit exactement à la même chose c'est
la déconstruction de l'europe c'est la
déconstruction de l'euro je combats
marine le pen parce que je suis
convaincu que dans cette élection
européenne ce qu'elle propose pour la
france c'est une sortie de l'histoire
ce serait le pire choix pour notre pays
que la déconstruction de l'europe
c'est pour cette raison que nous nous
battons contre marine le pen dans cette
élection et natacha comme tu me le
disait si bien oui notre famille croit
dans l'europe
oui notre famille et pour l'europe oui
c'est notre famille qui a été à
l'origine de la construction de l'europe
mais l'impasse l'autre impasse c'est
celle d' emmanuel macron qui consiste à
croire que il faut toujours plus de
l'europe qui ne marche pas c'est celle
qu'il incarne comme dans la première
phrase
le premier mot de la première
proposition de son programme c'est taxer
toujours plus de l'europe de la
bureaucratie toujours plus de l'europe
des impôts toujours plus de l'europe des
normes toujours plus d'élargissement j'y
reviendrai
il n'a pas compris que les français
croient dans l'europe
mais qu'ils veulent retrouver l'europe
qui marchait ils veulent retrouver
l'europe qui fonctionnait ils veulent
que nous répondions l'europe
ils veulent une europe puissance qui
soit capable de faire le bras de fer
avec les états unis et la chine
ils veulent une europe qui soient
capables de nous défendre parce qu'elle
sait qui elle est c'est cette europe que
nous nous voulons retrouver
c'est cette europe à laquelle emmanuel
macron lui tourner le dos son seul
objectif c'est une fuite en avant
il croit que l'on peut construire
l'europe sur les décombres des nations
nous nous voulons une europe qui
s'appuie sur les états qui s'appuie sur
les nations qui s'appuie sur les
frontières
c'est une europe civilisation que nous
nous voulons pour mener cette
refondation
j'ai voulu qu'on fasse confiance à une
nouvelle génération
j'ai voulu que cela puisse être françois
xavier qui tire notre liste parce que je
crois que la politique a besoin de
reprendre un peu de hauteur
je crois que la politique sabine
tellement avec ce qui change d'avis au
gré des sondages que la politique
s'abîme tellement avec ce jeu des
petites phrases ça fait du bien d'avoir
quelqu'un qui nous emmène vers le haut
et vous savez françois xavier a évoqué
ce débat
ce débat de france télévisions chacune
des têtes de listes étaient sommés
d'emmener un objet qui incarnait sa
vision de l'europe
et quand je les voyais les uns après les
autres
je me disais mais c'est pas possible que
la politique soit devenu ça on avait le
général de gaulle et pierre
mendès-france et maintenant on a ça la
tête de liste du rassemblement national
était venu pour incarner sa vision
profonde avec une passoire rouge
une autre tête de liste était venu avec
une paire de menottes sur lequel il
avait mis des petits autocollants jaunes
la tête de liste dans marche depuis n'en
voit plus dans les médias était avec des
piments d'espelette et nous notre tête
de liste était venu avec un livre et
qu'elle livre l'iliade d'homère c'était
quand même autre chose
merci françois xavier de tirer la liste
vers le haut avec des talents tout
autour de toi ils ont été évoqués venir
l'impact soit faustine les à karine tous
ceux qui sont ici il ya autre chose qui
me fait plaisir c'est le rassemblement
je déteste quand notre famille politique
se déchire et j'aime quand notre famille
politique se rassemblent et dans cette
campagne semaine après semaine notre
famille politique c'est rassembler et
elle s'est unie et comme je suis heureux
quand j'ai natacha à mes côtés qui est
non seulement une amie qui est une
compagnons de route mais qui à ce
caractère ingérable que j'adore natacha
ne change pas c'est parce que tu as
gérable que je t'aime
et c'est parce que tu as ingérable que
tu a métamorphosé calais et j'aime qu'il
y assurer côté pierre-henri qu'il y ait
daniel qui est tous ceux qui sont venus
de toute la région du nord bien sûr avec
sébastien brigitte de la somme avec al
inquiet de ce côté là avec les autres
élus de la somme qu'ils sont aussi
présents tout le monde est là et ça ça
me fait plaisir et j'aime qu'il y ait ce
rassemblement et cette unité de notre
famille des républicains
le maire de reims le maire de nice le
maire de toulouse
ils sont tous venus et au fur et à
mesure de la campagne il nous
apporter leur soutien pour moi c'est la
plus belle des récompenses c'est quand
notre famille est unie et rassemblée
parce qu'alors elle est invincible et
une unité que nous avons fait avec la
droite et le centre
parce que notre liste et la liste
d'union de la droite et du centre avec
les centristes hervé morin et une liste
que nous avons fait parce que je l' ai
voulu aussi parce que je n'aime pas la
façon dont on parle des chasseurs sur la
liste dans marche
je n'aime pas les propos inacceptables
de mépris qu'ils sont tenus par un
certain nombre de personnes qui sont sur
la liste dans marche et moi je n'oublie
pas que si l'on veut aboutir au respect
et l équilibre de la biodiversité
les chasseurs sont une composante dont
nous avons besoin comme les pêcheurs et
que eux connaissent la réalité de notre
milieu naturel
alors j'ai vu ce matin que le premier
ministre insultait la droite trocadéro
étonnant premier ministre étonnant
premier ministre et quand parfois je les
côtes où je le lis je me dis que
définitivement
il ne sait plus dans quel rue où ils
habitent il ne sait plus dans quel
quartier il habite
mais s'il ya une chose dont je suis sûr
c'est qu'en tout cas il n'est pas rive
droite
il n'est clairement pas raide droite
ce premier ministre explique donc qu'il
n'aime pas la droite trocadéro mais la
réalité c'est qu'il n'aime pas la droite
tout court la réalité c'est qu'il n'aime
plus la droite
il n'aime plus la droite trocadéro parce
que c'est la droite qui ne renonce pas
il n'aime pas la droite trocadéro celle
qui était aux côtés de nicolas sarkozy
comme de françois fillon parce que c'est
la droite qui ne baisse pas la tête
il n'aime pas la droite trocadéro parce
que c'est la droite qui ne trahit pas
lui qui a rejoint emmanuel macron à
l'arrière d'une voiture conduite par
bella avec une couverture sur la tête
il n'aime pas la droite trocadéro parce
que c'est celle qui lui dit non monsieur
le premier ministre non monsieur le
président de la république ce que vous
faites ça n'est pas une politique de
droite
on n'est pas à droite quand on traite
comme ils l'ont traité les retraités de
france en leur prenant 8 milliards
d'euros
on n'est pas on n'est pas à droite quand
on est incapable en deux ans de faire le
moindre économie sur la dépense publique
et comme on est réduit d'une façon ou
d'une autre à prendre dans la poche des
français on n'est pas à droite quand
dans le programme de sa liste on ne
mentionne même pas l'islamisme et que la
tête de liste madame l'oiseau explique
que pour elle il n'y a aucune différence
entre le voile islamique et le fichu que
portaient nos grands-mères honte à celui
qui peut porter cela
on n'est pas à droite quand on fait
soutenir sa liste par cohn bendit et que
le numéro deux de cette liste est un
ancien ministre de françois hollande qui
s'est toujours opposé à toute régulation
contre l'immigration irrégulière
on n'est pas à droite quand on est
incapable de rétablir l'ordre semaine
après semaine et que celui qui est censé
incarner la fermeté est un ministre de
l'intérieur comme monsieur castaner dont
on a compris la réalité de ce qu'ils
inspiraient et enfin mes amis on n'est
pas à droite quand le directeur de
campagne de la liste en marche a osé
déclarer que bien évidemment dès
l'élection passée il ferait des
alliances avec les socialistes au parti
heureux au parlement européen et qu'ils
avaient l'intention de siéger avec les
socialistes
nous nous sommes à droite nous la droite
est de retour et je le dis à tous ceux
qui sont attachés aux valeurs de la
droite c'est le moment de vous exprimer
fait le choix de la seule liste qui
porte à la fois la conviction de
l'europe et les valeurs de la droite et
du centre dans cette campagne européenne
[Applaudissements]
l'europe l'europe
l'aviez sans doute le seul à vraiment
parler d'europe qu'est ce que c'est que
l'europe qu'on fait les pères fondateurs
quand ils ont choisi ce drapeau sur ce
drapeau ils ont mis les étoiles de la
couronne de la vierge
les étoiles de la couronne de la vierge
que fait le général de gaulle quand il
veut réconcilier la france et
l'allemagne aient jeté sur les fonts
baptismaux
les élans qui porteront ensuite la
construction européenne quels lieux
positive ne va pas bruxelles ne va pas à
paris ne va pas berlin il va dans la
cathédrale de reims il va dans cette
cathédrale qui avait été détruite par
les allemands pendant la première guerre
mondiale et il montre ainsi que c'est
aux origines de nos racines chrétiennes
et de notre histoire qu'il va aller
puiser la refondation de l'europe
que font-ils que font-ils
mais comment ne pas le voir il faut
évidemment un projet de civilisation ce
qui les hantent
c'est une question toute simple comment
assurer un avenir à ce que nous sommes
comment faire en sorte que ce que nous
avons reçu puisse ensuite être transmis
c'est cela qui les habitent
pourquoi est-ce que nous sommes là parce
que c'est la même question qui nous
hante
comment arriver à assurer l'avenir de
l'europe
comment faire en sorte que la voix si
singulière de notre civilisation ne se
perdent pas comment faire en sorte que
nous ne soyons pas forcé de changer de
mode de vie alors que nous ne le
souhaitons pas pourquoi êtes vous là
parce que nous aimons tous notre
identité notre culture notre
civilisation que nous voyons les menaces
la chine les etats unis l'islamisme le
danger de décrochage de notre économie
et que nous ce que nous voulons c'est
redonner un avenir et du souffle à cette
civilisation européenne et
françois-xavier le sol a parlé de cela
les autres parlent de bureaucratie les
autres parlent de commission européenne
les autres parlent de bruxelles les
autres parlent de l'union européenne
nous nous parlons de l'essentiel nous
parlons de la civilisation
nous parlons de notre identité nous
parlons de notre culture nous parlons de
nos valeurs nous parlons de ce que nous
aimons du fond de notre coeur parce que
nous savons que si cela est perdu tout
le reste
a perdu marc et je suis très heureux que
notre meeting se soit tenue ici dans le
calaisis
parce que le calaisis se sont pas
seulement des résistants ce sont des
guerriers parce que dans le calaisis
même quand tout semble abattu on ne
renonce jamais et moi j'aime qu'on
combatte ainsi en ayant la passion
charnelle de son territoire c'est les
choses qui me parle
marc marc ça veut dire la frontière une
civilisation qu'est ce que c'est d'abord
c'est d'abord une frontière
il y à quelque chose qui est à
l'intérieur il ya quelque chose qui est
à l'extérieur
et bien mes amis je vous le dis dans
cette campagne
une de nos différences majeures par
rapport à la liste dans marche c'est que
la liste dans marche et pour
l'élargissement emmanuel macron a
expliqué qu'il fallait ouvrir l'europe
aux balkans il s'apprête à ouvrir les
négociations pour l'adhésion de
l'albanie l'albanie mes amis à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne et il
est allé dire à bucarest qu'il fallait
que la bulgarie et la roumanie entre le
plus vite possible à l'intérieur de
l'espace schengen c'est une folie dites
le autour de vous c'est une des raisons
essentielles pour lesquelles il ne faut
pas signé de chèque en blanc pour la
liste en marche
nous notre discours est très clair tous
ceux qui sont sur notre liste signeront
mercredi une charte d'engagement dans
laquelle il s'engage à voter contre
toute décision qui aboutirait un
élargissement supplémentaire de l'union
européenne et il y a eu trop de pays
[Applaudissements]
et la deuxième et vous le savez ici
mieux qu'ailleurs
si on a des frontières c'est qu'il faut
les défendre la tâche a d'abord je veux
le dire je n'aime pas que qu'elle est
soit résumer à cela
calais c'est bien d'autres choses calais
c'est le dynamisme de ces commerçants
calais c'est un port qui alors que tout
espoir semblait perdu au lendemain de la
seconde guerre mondiale et que tout
était détruit a su complètement se
reconvertir calais c'est une de nos
principales façade maritime qu'elle est
c'est la fierté de tout les labels que
tu as réussi à voir est notamment très
récemment
ce label du patrimoine qu'elle est c'est
ceux-là d'abord attention là dessus
parce qu'il ya la dentelle de calais
mais il ya surtout la dentelle du puy en
velay et ça c'est ma ville
et là je ne rigole pas mais mes amis
comment ne pas comprendre quand on vient
ici à quel point on s'est mis la tête à
l'envers
bien sûr les choses vont mieux et elle
vaut mieux parce que natacha s'est battu
mais la france ça ne peut pas être ça
j'étais tout à l'heure dans l'entreprise
paul est une entreprise extraordinaire
fondée par le grand-père qui
transportait du charbon
développé par le père qui a fait dix
salariés transformé par le petit fils
qui a réussi à en faire une très belle
entreprise qui fait 70 salariés et qui
embauche je vous parlerai dans les
chances que j'ai eu avec une des
salariées et qui dit beaucoup de choses
pour moi de ce que nous voulons pour
l'europe mais il est obligé de se
protéger avec des barbelés il est obligé
d'avoir un gars de chiens il est obligé
de faire passer tout camion qu'il veut
ensuite prendre le tunnel où allait
prendre les bateaux dans le port à
travers un détecteur pour vérifier qu'il
n'ya pas un migrant qui a éventré les
choses et qui s'est pas cachée derrière
une caisse et c'est cela l'europe
ça ne peut pas être seul à l'europe et
le ministre de l'intérieur vient ensuite
ici en disant de toute façon il faudra
s'habituer à voir et régulièrement des
gens qui sont ici et qui n'ont aucune
raison d'être ici
et bien je le dis ça n'est pas
acceptable ça n'est pas à la france de
faire le garde frontière pour le royaume
uni
que le royaume uni gère lui même ces
demandeurs d'asile voilà ce que nous
devons exiger et oui comme
françois-xavier l'a expliqué nous nous
demandons que toutes les demandes
d'asile soit faite sur le continent
africain
parce que quand les gens sont chez nous
c'est trop tard c'est trop tard et la
deuxième chose on nous parle d'une
immigration familiale
mais il suffit de venir à calais pour
comprendre que ça n'est pas une
immigration familiale
il suffit de venir ici pour le
comprendre il suffit de comprendre que
cela n'a pas de sens c'est que ça n'est
pas la vraie générosité
natacha comme tu l'a très bien dit la
vraie générosité c'est la vérité la
vérité c'est celle qui consiste à dire
que l'avenir de l'afrique ne peut pas
être en europe l'avenir de la jeunesse
africaine doit être en afrique et nous
notre devoir c'est d'aider le
développement de l'afrique et de
demander en contrepartie que les pays
africains s'engagent à reprendre leurs
ressortissants qui sont entrés
irrégulièrement sur le continent
européen
ça c'est la vraie générosité l'avenir
est en afrique une civilisation ensuite
ce sont des projets communs nous ne
sommes pas pour l'europe des normes
nous ne sommes pas meilleurs pour que la
france rajoute encore d'énormes aux
normes parce que nous comme on croit
être plus intelligente tous les autres
quand l'europe fait une norme les belges
prennent la plus simple les allemands
prennent la plus simple et nous nous
prenons la plus folle et les
britanniques eux à ce stade refuse même
de les appliquer c'est encore plus
simple pas les normes les projets
l'europe qui nous parlait pourquoi
l'europe ne fait d'airtel pas tous les
centres de recherche d'europe pendant
cinq ans pour les faire travailler sur
ce défi immense que sont les maladies
neurodégénératives et alzheimer
moi vous savez
j'ai une grand mère que je chérissais
plus que tout une grand mère qui m'a
élevé ma maman était tout seuls et
travailler cette grand mère elle était
belge parce que j'ai un quart de sang
belle vous le savez ma famille partie de
ses racines ici entre la belgique et la
france sur ce territoire du nord cette
grand mère elle a été emportée par cette
maladie et pour moi c'était une épreuve
terrible de la voir elle qui avait
tellement d'énergie tellement dynamisme
qui était si intelligente si brillante
et qui étaient emportées par cette
maladie terrifiantes au fur et à mesure
vous perdez le contact avec l'être cher
où vous avez l'impression qu'on vous
vole votre mémoire ce que vous avez de
plus précieux et qui normalement reste y
compris après la mort et où les derniers
instants sont des instants que vous
voudriez vivre si intensément et dans
lesquels on vous prive de les changes
les derniers mots des changes que vous
pouvez avoir c'est une épreuve qui est
l'épreuve psychologique c'est une
épreuve morale et c'est une épreuve
physique aussi pour les familles qui
sont confrontées
c'est sans doute le pire fléau du 21e
siècle je rêverais que l'europe se fixe
ça comme on veut et qu'on puisse revenir
en disant vous voulez savoir à quoi sert
l'europe et ben l'europe asservie a
servi à vaincre la maladie d'alzheimer
et redonner juste ce repos ces dernières
minutes ces instants aux familles qui
ont été frappés par alzheimer que
d'ailleurs les gens qui partent soit
jeune ou avait parce que la maladie
d'alzheimer frappe sans distinction
ça c'est l'europe à laquelle je crois
c'est l'europe des projets
et l'autre europe que j'aime c'est celle
du travail le travail ici on sait ce que
c'est que le travail ici on s'est
toujours battu pour remonter la pente
quand tout semblait perdu
ici on est attaché à cette valeur dans
cette entreprise où j'étais il y avait
une femme qui a forcément respect
coralie elle avait perdu son job
elle est repartie sur un parcours
d'insertion commerçante elle avait été
ruinée elle était repartie m'a dit je
n'étais pas dans le bon créneau pas
éclos bonne associés j'ai tout perdu
elle est reparti tout en bas elle a
suivi un parcours d'insertion
elle a passé son cas c'est ce quand on
est une femme c'est pas facile et elle
était employée dans cette entreprise de
transport où elle était dans le hall
logistique et où avec son chariot elle
s'occupait d'organiser le stock est bien
cette femme elle a forcément respect
parce que pour une coralie combien y en
at il qui eux restent tranquillement
chez eux à vivre des prestations
sociales accumulés et à vivre de
l'assistanat
ça ça n'est pas le vrai sociale le vrai
social c'est celui de coralie le vrai
social c'est celui qui consiste à aider
les gens qui sont en difficulté parce
que tout le monde peut être en
difficulté mais leur tendre la main en
leur disant il faut se retrousser les
manches se sera pas facile mais on va
vous aider parce que le vrai sociales
comme le disait ma grand mère ça n'est
pas de donner du poisson mais c'est de
ré apprendre à pêcher
moi je ne crois pas au social par
l'assistanat je crois au sociale par le
travail
c'est ce social là que j'aime et dans
notre famille politique
on est fier de ceux qui travaillent on
défend nos entreprises il faut défendre
la préférence européenne pour nos
entreprises et il faut retrouver la
préférence européenne pour nos
agriculteurs
il y a dans cette salle des agriculteurs
je veux le dire qu'on est fiers de ce
qu'ils font
la france a la chance d'avoir des
exploitations agricoles familiales qui
font du bon travail
arrêtons de critiquer nos agriculteurs
et retrouvons la préférence agricole le
gouvernement s'apprête à mettre des
boules et au piano agriculteurs et
ensuite importer de la viande du brésil
et d'amérique latine
bourré aux activateur de croissance et
on fait la même chose avec les céréales
ça n'a pas de bon sens ça n'a pas de bon
sens
[Applaudissements]
et la dernière chose mes amis avec
laquelle je voudrais conclure une
civilisation c'est une culture une
culture c'est précieux
une civilisation c'est fragile en ce
moment vous le savez il y a des gens qui
veulent mettre à bas tout ce que nous
sommes tous que nous portons parfois des
gens qui sont nés sur le sol français
née sur le continent européen et qui ont
tourné leur haine contre la france et
contre l'europe et nous ne faisons rien
et dans son programme la liste en marche
n'évoque même pas une fois le mot
islamisme même pas une fois quand on a
fondé la république française et qu'il y
a eu la laïcité
on a exigé de l'église catholique bien
des efforts pour s'adapter et elle les a
faits pour concilier la république avec
ce qu est l église catholique et
aujourd'hui nous avons face à nous un
intégrisme l'islamisme politique qui tue
qui abat et on ne fait rien nous nous
portons des revendications qui sont
claires pour faire en sorte qu'il y ait
un pacte européen contre l'islamisme il
faut prendre les vraies mesures
les vraies mesures ça veut dire d'abord
qu'il faut fermer toutes les mosquées
salafistes en europe
il faut fermer toutes les mosquées
la deuxième chose bien sûr qu'il faut
faire c'est que quentin imams prêchent
la haine il faut le mettre dehors parce
qu'un imams qui prêchent la haine il n'y
a aucune raison qu'ils restent sur le
sol français
arrêtons de laisser le travail de
propagande se faire à l'ombre de nos
mosquées et c'est un tort aussi parce
que quand on laisse ce travail-là ce
faire on laisse petit à petit les
musulmans modérés être obligé de baisser
le regard parce qu'on laisse les
intégristes prennent prendre la main sur
les quartiers ça n'est pas cela la
république ce n'est pas cela la
république
et la dernière chose là dessus les
djihadistes savez je suis allé à mossoul
parce que dans ma région nous avons un
programme de soutien aux minorités
chrétienne en orient
j'ai vu ce qui s'était passé là bas j'ai
vu cette ville qui a été rasé j'ai
échangé avec un père de famille qui
avait perdu tous ses enfants tous ses
enfants ses sept enfants qui avait été
tué et massacré juste parce qu'il
n'avait pas la bonne religion
j'ai vu cet immeuble où les djihadistes
prenez ceux qui ne partageaient pas leur
religion leur mettaient un sac sur la
tête et les précipiter diot du building
pour qu'ils agonise pendant des heures
ensuite en ayant le cou brisé
j'ai vu ce terrain de foot où il faisait
jouer des gamins disant pas avec des
ballons de foot avec les têtes de ceux
qu'ils avaient décapité cela mes amis
sont les atrocités qui ont été commises
là-bas et le président de la république
le gouvernement a accepté que 200
djihadistes reviennent en france
nous nous demandons une seule chose nous
nous demandons une seule chose que
l'europe craint un tribunal
international en irak que ce tribunal
international juge en irak
les djihadistes qu'il soit condamné en
irak et qu'ils restent en irak
ils ne doivent pas revenir en france ou
en europe
[Applaudissements]
et comment tout cela s'est passé ici on
est sur un territoire dans lequel je
suis sûr que bien des visages ici
pourrait en témoigner
on s'est construit avec aussi des
apports de population qui venait
d'ailleurs des gens qui venaient de
belgique qui venait de pologne qui
venait d'espagne qui venait du portugal
qui venaient d'italie qui venaient du
sud de la méditerranée et qui se sont
intégrés
elles se sont intégrées parce qu'en
arrivant elle disait à leurs enfants
nous venons ici pour travailler ne me
fait pas honte respecte les règles de ce
nouveau pays apprend dur étudie dur
apprend le français écoutent à l'école
et surtout comprend qu'à compter de ce
jour la france c'est ton pays voilà ce
qu'était l'extraordinaire histoire de
l'intégration française et que s'est il
passé
mais nous avons inversé ce devoir
d'intégration
nous avons cru qu'à cueillir l'autre cet
effet en sorte que c'était à nous de
nous adapter aux modes de vie de l'autre
au lieu de comprendre que c'est tout
l'un vers ce qu'il faut faire c'est
qu'il faut prendre par la main celui qui
arrive pour lui expliquer ce que sont
les règles
ce qu'est le mode de vie du pays dans
lequel il a choisi de s'installer ça
n'est pas à la france de s'adapter à
celui qui vient de l'étranger
c'est à celui qui vient de l'étranger de
s'adapter à la france sans c'est la
vraie intégration
ça c'est la bonne intégration
et bien pour cela mes amis il faut
retrouver la fierté de ce que nous
sommes
oui il faut faire en sorte que les
racines chrétiennes soirée inscrite dans
les traités européens
oui il faut ré enseigner l'histoire de
france dans nos écoles
oui nous ne pouvons pas accepter que
l'on renonce à faire par exemple un
voyage de classe à la cathédrale de
reims parce que vous avez des élèves qui
vont expliquer que ça n'est pas
compatible avec leur religion
oui on ne peut pas accepter que dans un
hôpital il y un médecin homme auquel on
dise qu'il ne peut pas intervenir sur
une patiente femmes même si elle est en
urgence vitale parce que ça n'est pas
compatible avec sa religion vous
explique son mari
oui on ne peut pas accepter en france
qu'une femme dans un quartier n'est plus
le choix de la façon dont elle s'habille
parce qu'on lui explique que la religion
l'obligent à se couvrir
ça n'est pas cela la france à chaque
fois que nous reculons sur un petit bout
de ce que nous sommes c'est une partie
de notre civilisation que l'on perd
pourquoi pourquoi mes amis pourquoi n'ai
jamais voulu renoncer sur la question
des crèches ce symbole qui semble en
apparence si anodin parce que les
crèches est un petit bout de ce que nous
sommes et qu'à chaque fois qu'on se
soumet à chaque fois qu on recule on se
perd je ne veux pas de cela alors
retrouvons oui dans cette campagne des
européennes la fierté de notre culture
ici vous êtes dans le calaisis
ici c'est ce site magnifique qui est au
confluent de la mer du nord et de la
manche ce site magnifique où commence la
côte d'opale où seuls ceux qui ne sont
pas venus ne pas pu se laisser ébahir
par la qualité extraordinaire de la
lumière dans les ciels qui sont
traversés par le vent moi j'aime cette
côte d'opale parce qu'elle dit quelque
chose du dynamisme de la pugnacité et de
la beauté de la nature quand elle est
aussi authentique ici c'est calais c'est
un endroit qui a souvent vécu les
épreuves qui a marqué l'histoire de
france à travers l'héroïsme de sa
résistance face à l'envahisseur anglais
les bourgeois de calais cela dit quelque
chose de ce qu'est l'esprit de la
résistance ici ici à calais plus des
deux tiers de la ville ont été plusieurs
fois mis à bas
jamais vous n'avez renoncer ici à calais
comme dans ce territoire du nord de la
france des hauts de france
vous remontez toujours la pente même
quand tout semble perdu et bien j'aime
cela il n'y a pas de destruction
définitive il n'y a jamais d'espoir
définitivement perdu il n'y a jamais
rien qui ne peut pas être reconstruit
pourquoi est ce que nous avons décidé de
porter cet emblème refonder l'europe
rétablir la france parce que précisément
ici à calais plus qu'ailleurs
vous le savez on ne renonce jamais on ne
baisse jamais le regard on regarde
toujours vers la mer on regarde toujours
vers l'horizon et on arrive à déjouer
les pires tempêtes et les pires défaites
c'est cela ce que je vous demande de
faire
il nous reste 14 jours la reconstruction
de notre famille politique a commencé la
capacité à faire résonner à nouveau avec
fierté ce qu'est la voix de la droite a
commencé
je suis convaincu que la france et
l'europe en ont besoin on peut déjouer
dans cette campagne tous les pronostics
mais j'ai besoin de vous il ya quelque
chose qui a commencé aidez-nous dans ses
14 jours pour le transformer en un
mouvement qu'on n'arrêtera plus vive la
france et vive l'europe